speaker Kevin McCarthy Kevin let's talk
about that 1023 form you had obviously
somebody that the FBI relied on
you had a a an informant that they paid
hundreds of thousands of dollars to he's
directly reporting what the head of
Barista saying about how he's paying Joe
and Hunter Biden all of this money all
these millions to protect them uh from
the investigations that were ongoing and
in fact we have Joe Biden on tape
admitting and bragging about it and
Hunter admitting he had no experience
but was paid all this money uh what word
would you use to describe that that
incident if you will
well there's a ledge 1023 that claims
that the that they bribe the bidens okay
this was given to the FBI when Bill Barr
finally found out about it he sent it to
his office in Philadelphia they actually
said that this was very credible the FBI
kept this from the IRS individuals for
them ever to see it so not only do they
claim that they were bribed We Now find
information that 16 out of 17 payments
from Romania were provided to the Biden
shell companies while he was vice
president
when President Biden was running for
office he told the American public that
he's never talked about business he said
his family has never received a dollar
from China which we now prove is not
true we now have some of the most
credible whistleblowers these 10-year
IRS agents who have come forward said
that the Biden family has been treated
differently that what Weiss has told us
is different than what Garland and Weiss
has told the public and you're sitting
here today where now you have found
millions of foreign money just with the
1023 alleges they did to Biden's family
now we found that it has funneled
through shell companies if you're
sitting in our position today we would
know none of this if Republicans had not
taken the majority we've only followed
where the information has taken us but
rising to the level of impeachment
inquiry which provides Congress the
strongest power to get the rest of the
knowledge and information needed because
this president has also used something
we have not seen since Richard Nixon use
the weaponization of government to
benefit his family and deny Congress the
ability to have the oversight if we are
talking about millions of dollars coming
from our top geopolitical foes and that
the Biden family has been corrupted and
and took in all of this money and he was
complicit in that wouldn't that wouldn't
that
wouldn't that mean that we have a
criminal Enterprise
as president of the United States that
had to be on every level compromised by
countries that are not particularly fond
of us
well it's interesting that the Biden
family runs if they say a company but
never had an office and shell companies
to be able to pay through but if they
really ran it for foreign countries why
didn't you get money from France from
Germany from UK why does it have to be
from China Romania into these countries
that have real challenges and had
problems going through I believe we will
follow this all the way to the end and
this is going to rise to an impeachment
inquiry the way the Constitution tells
us to do this and we have to get the
answers to these questions in the words
of John Dean and malignant cancer now is
surrounding the Biden presidency and
those walls are closing awfully tight
this is not going the way I'm sure they
wanted it to and then we have on the
other side of it the assistance of the
doj and the FBI that's Jim Jordan's
committee Mr speaker thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis says you will not get it
anywhere else